[Music]
foreign
book in history no volume ever written
has been more loved and quoted and its
words sometimes simple and sometimes
mysterious should always be studied
carefully it is the Bible the word of
God welcome to Bible answers live
providing accurate and practical answers
to all your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call
800-835-6747 once again that's
800-835-6747 now here's your host from
amazing facts International Pastor Doug
Batchelor Hello friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact
back in 1829 two men George Wilson and
James Porter robbed the United States
mail carrier both were captured tried
and sentenced to execution by hanging
Porter was executed on schedule but
Wilson was not influential friends
pleaded on his behalf for Mercy to the
president of the United States Andrew
Jackson
president Jackson relented and issued a
formal pardon dropping all charges
Wilson would still have to serve a
20-year prison term for his prior crimes
incredibly George Wilson refused the
pardon
so what do you do with a pardon that's
rejected
the Supreme Court stepped in to decide
what happens to a person that does not
accept a presidential pardon
after some research Chief Justice John
Marshall stated a pardon refused is no
pardon
George Wilson must be hanged and he was
kind of hard to imagine Pastor Ross a
person has offered a pardon from
execution
and they say I don't want it they reject
it
it's kind of sad to have a pardon and
then reject it but in a spiritual sense
there are many in the world today who
have rejected the pardon that has been
offered to them at Great cost through
the cross through the crucifixion of
Christ and yet they spur that pardon and
they push that aside yeah they're not
only being saved from Death they're
being saved from an eternal death and
the Bible calls it the second death and
God is extending this incredible grace
and mercy there's a number of verses in
the Bible sort of highlight this uh this
scorn or rejected pardon you can read in
Proverbs 1 verse 24. it says because I
called to you and you refused I've
stretched out my hand and no one
regarded and the Lord is stretching out
his hand he's calling to the world and
saying whosoever will let him take the
Water of Life and so many people are
just saying no I'm not interested no no
reason is given in history why George
Wilson refused the pardon
uh you know you can only speculate but
he said I don't want it
and sounds sad it is sad well you know
Pastor Doug we do have a book that talks
about the riches of God's grace and uh
the Forgiveness they got office to
everyone it's free we got to receive it
by faith we'd be happy to send the book
to anyone who calls and asks the number
for the book is 800.
[Music]
um
835-6747 that is the resource phone line
and you can just ask for uh offer number
one five two it's called Riches of his
grace and we'll be happy to send it to
anyone in Canada or in the U.S and if
you're outside of North America you can
just go to our website just
amazingfacts.org you can also request
the book by just on your cell phone
pound 250 and say Bible answers live and
then you can ask for the book The Riches
of his grace and we'll be happy to send
it to anyone who calls and asks well
Pastor Doug we want to greet all of
those who are joining us and we have
folks watching on AF TV we also have
people listening across the country on
on various radio stations and of course
on the internet and they can watch live
on the Doug Batchelor Facebook page on
the amazing facts Facebook page on
YouTube on Roku some other outlets so I
want to welcome all of those who are
joining us this is our Live program so
if you have a Bible question
the phone line to our studio is 800 God
says that's
804-63-7297
800-463-7297 with your Bible question
amen well before we go to the phone
lines let's start with the word of
Prayer dear father we thank you that we
have this time once again to open up
your word and study Lord we recognize
there is power in your word and we ask
for the spirit to come and guide us be
with those who are listening wherever
they might be in their car or at home or
whatever they're doing Lord and guide us
into a clearer and a full understanding
of your word Jesus said you'll know the
truth and the truth will set you free so
bless our time together in Jesus name
amen amen
all right well we're ready to go to our
first call of this evening we've got
Gary listening in Illinois Gary welcome
to Bible answers live
thank you in Revelation 7 3 it says that
the angels are told not to hurt Earth
until the Servants of God are sealed in
their forehead so since they're Servants
of God already why do they need to be
sealed in their forehead and if you
don't have that seal in Revelation 9 4
you will be hurt
so that's my question what is the Seal
of that
yeah first and foremost the Seal of God
is the Holy Spirit you can read that in
Ephesians chapter 2. I think there's
probably two or three places that talks
about uh grief not the Holy Spirit we're
with you are sealed unto the day of
redemption but then there's something in
Revelation beyond that uh obviously
those who have the mark of the beast
have the spirit of the devil those that
have the Seal of God have the spirit of
God I think that kind of goes without
saying and
you can read in Isaiah chapter 8 it says
bind up the testimony seal the law among
my disciples
so when you look in Deuteronomy chapter
6. Moses says to the children of Israel
hear o Israel this is verse 4 the Lord
our God is one Thou shalt love of the
Lord your God with all your heart mind
soul and strength and these words I
command you today he had just quoted the
Ten Commandments in chapter five these
words I command you today shall be in
your heart you shall write them on the
doors of your house when you go out when
you come in they shall be as frontless
between your eyes and they shall be
written upon your hands
so when he says that the law of God is
to be sealed among his people that's
talking about it is to be ingrained it's
to be embedded in their nature the Bible
says that it they have he says I will
give you a heart where you want to do my
will I'll write my law in your hearts
now God's people of the Holy Spirit
but when they're sealed with the holy
spirit it's they reach the point where
they just can't be lost just like those
who get the mark of the beast can't be
saved absolutely Pastor you know it's
also interesting Jesus said if you love
me keep my Commandments and you're
speaking about the Seal of God it's the
Holy Spirit but the holy spirit is
Manifest in the life of a Believer
through obedience Revelation chapter 12
17 talks about a group of people who
have well they keep the Commandments of
God and they have the testimony of Jesus
in Revelation 14 12 says they have the
faith of Jesus so those who keep God's
Commandments because they love him and
they have the Holy Spirit in the last
days there'll be two groups those with
the Seal of God and those of the mark of
the beast and the issue revolves around
worship and you know we do have a study
guide that talks about or talks about
the mark of the beast but by default it
will also talk about the Seal of God
because you need both of them if you'd
like to learn more about the subject uh
just call and ask ask for the study
guide is called the mark of the beast
and we'll be happy to send that out to
anyone who calls and asks the number
again is
800-835-6747 that is a resource phone
line you can also dial pound 250 say
Bible answers live and say I want that
study guide the mark of the beast if you
have a Bible question a phone lines here
to the studio is
800-463-7297 thank you Gary we got
Archie listening California Archie
welcome to the program
thank you uh Pastor Ross
how are you doing uh Pastor Doug good
appreciate your calling
okay uh my question involves
Deuteronomy
14.
verse 22 and then 24 to 26. I'd like to
know
uh it doesn't seem like it's telling
people to use their ties for what it's
meant for
yeah good question
yeah I appreciate that and before we
even give the answer for anyone out
there that has a question about what
does the Bible say regarding tithe we
will mention the free offer we have
called in God you trust and God We Trust
we also have that book called thieves in
the church but let me get to the point
of your question here there were two
kinds of ties there was the regular tie
that was given throughout the year on
their increase whether that increase was
crops or herds or or money
they were to consecrate a tenth of all
their increase that was a general across
the board tie the tenth of their income
their increase
was to be consecrated to the Lord given
to the Levites for their work of
ministry the Levites keep in mind they
were not just the pastors they taught
the word of God throughout the land they
were something like the doctors as well
they were the judges and so it was you
know you can call it a text but it was
more of a spiritual tax but the tithe
that's being mentioned here in
Deuteronomy 14 was a tithe that was
given especially for the feasts when
they would come up to these annual
feasts and not all the feasts required
them to come but I think there were
three feasts that required them to come
before the Lord and these are tithes
connected with that
and if you want to apply that to a New
Testament time period not only do we
have our ties which is 10 of an increase
but we also give offerings and offerings
it's not a set amount but as the needs
arise in the church if there's a special
project or evangelism or just to sustain
the work of the local church that's what
offerings get used for yeah New and Old
Testament talk about tithe and offerings
and of course in the Old Testament you
got Malachi chapter 3 talks about that
and Jesus mentions the tithe in I think
it's Matthew 23 23. and we do have a
study guide talking about that it's
called In God We Trust and again just
call
800-835-6747 ask for the study guide is
called in God we trust you can also ask
to the book it's called these in the
church and just ask and we'll be happy
to send it to anyone who calls and asks
next quarter that we have is Kathy
listening in North Carolina Kathy you're
on Bible answers live
hi gentlemen thank you for my taking my
call yeah
um okay I've got a question on
praying multiple times for the same
object I mean it seems to me if you just
ask in faith can you sit there and you
go okay well you either you're going to
say yes no or wait a while and but I
sort of get the impression from some
scripture that like the Jesus talking
about the woman like going to the judge
and going hey you know please please
please you're going to some guy going
please please please give me and finally
he her persistence wore him down and and
he gave her what she wanted and I wasn't
sure if that was Jesus saying you know
keep keep on going to till you get some
sort of answer or I mean just like I
don't do that with my kids I don't say
okay if you keep begging me enough you
get a different answer because you won't
you don't beg me right because yes no
we're all think about it but you just
then you shut up yeah I agree with you
on that and by the way you're quoting a
parable that Jesus shares in Luke 18
about the persistent Widow who continues
to pray until she gets the answer from
this unrighteous judge there's nothing
wrong with praying multiple times over
something I think anyone who is a parent
out there prays all the time for their
kids and in the Lord's Prayer it says
give me this day my daily bread that
implies that it doesn't say give me my
bread for the rest of my life that you
know some things we just continue to
thank the Lord for and pray for on an
ongoing basis
Jesus said not to pray in vain
repetition meaning you don't just repeat
a memorized prayer there's no value in
that that just wears God down but to
have an ongoing issue that you're
praying about now Paul continued to pray
to the Lord about what he called the
thorn in his side I forget what that
verse is
and after he prayed about it three times
God said don't let's not talk about it
anymore I'm not answering that prayer
and so but Paul obviously he prayed more
than once about it so there was no sin
Elijah prayed seven times for rain in
First Kings after the fire came down
from heaven he then prayed seven times
he kept sending his servant to see did
is God sending the rain so sometimes you
want to persist in prayer if you know
that it's something according to God's
will
you may be praying for loved ones for
years yeah I was just going to add I
don't think God doesn't want to hear us
pray but I think he wants sincerity in
our prayer so if it's just a vain
repetition we don't mean what we are
saying that doesn't have value but if
it's an Earnest desire and maybe there
are times we've got to bring up
something multiple times before the Lord
uh for strength our own strength to gain
the victory or in the situation of you
know a relationship or a need for
healing but we don't want to do the vain
repetition right yeah I pray for Mercy
every day you need that yep
all right we do have a book it's called
teach us to pray and we'll be happy to
send this to you Kathy anyone wanting to
learn more the number is
800-835-6747 after the book it's called
teach us to pray or perhaps to send it
to you in Canada if you're listening or
in North America if you're outside of
the U.S just got our website
amazingfacts.org and if you have a Bible
question a phone line here at the studio
is 800-463-7297
Randy's listening in Indiana Randy
welcome to Bible answers live
good evening thank you my question is
about hell uh the Bible does say in our
Revelation that at the very end when the
wicked finally say just ensure thy ways
that fire is going to come down from
heaven and devour them my question
specifically is is that fire literally
going to come down or is God going to
reveal his face to the world and they're
going to basically be incinerated
because the Bible also says that no man
has ever seen God and lived right well
you're actually you're you're on to
something you're looking at two
different events the wicked are
destroyed by the brightness of his
coming I believe that's second
Thessalonians so when Jesus comes the
Brighton of his of his coming is going
to just destroy the wicked but at the
end of the 1000 years it says the rest
of the Dead don't live till the thousand
years are finished that's revelation 20.
that means the rest of the Dead the
wicked are raised at the end of the 1000
years they are then ultimately judged
and then God Reigns fire down upon them
he literally reigned fire upon the
people in Sodom and Gomorrah the Bible
says the destruction of the wicked will
be like Sodom and Gomorrah and it keeps
raining down just like in the days of
Noah when it rained down it finally
turned into a flood and a lake the whole
world was covered it rains down outside
the New Jerusalem and it creates what
they call a lake of fire and of course
the devil and his angels must be
physically thrown into that Lake of Fire
tells us that's what happens to them so
the Wicked the devil and the angels are
all cast into this Lake of Fire God
rains it down it's you could say coming
from every direction you know we have a
study guide It's called is the devil in
charge of hell and it talks about the
fire that consumes the Wicked at the end
how long is the fire what is the fire
accomplished all of that's answered in
the book is the devil in charge of Hell
the number for that is 800-835-6747
women and again just ask for the study
guide It's called is the devil in charge
of hell and we do have a website pass
today it's called helltruth.com which is
helltruth.com a lot of great information
there also some studies some Bible
references so take a look at that we've
got Joshua listening in Kentucky Joshua
welcome to Bible answers live
hey how are you guys tonight doing good
thank you for calling well I remember
seeing Doug reclaim your faith I think I
scared him in DC wants to put my hand on
his shoulder and said hi dog he turned
around uh don't remember being scared
but uh sorry I don't remember
well I had a question for you you know
the 144 000 is a topic that seems to
keep coming up and and this last day
theology that I'm hearing about there's
only going to be 144 000 perfect people
standing
uh when Christ comes back it will be
translated to heaven and I just find
that hard to believe uh based on if
there is an exact exacting number of 144
000 the percentage of that compared to
eight billion people on planet Earth
would be very slim possibility of going
to heaven and the other factor is the
predestination uh theology if there's
only is it really only 144 that are
predestined to go to heaven or be
translated
and I think this this theology is like
out of out of control spreading like a
wildfire and I just find that hard to
believe and you know the Judgment the
other part of the question is uh people
are scared of the Judgment this
investigative judgment that's going on I
said well why are you scared you're
going to be looked at whether you're
dead and look or going through the books
or what you're doing before in your life
when Christ is coming back I would just
like to expound on these two topics
briefly if you can okay first of all the
144 000 mentioned in Revelation chapter
7 Revelation 14. uh is it a literal
number I believe it is but they are not
the only ones saved so I would just say
the 144 000 it talks about 12 000 from
the Twelve Tribes
Jesus had 12 Apostles that reached the
great multitude Jesus not only had 12
Apostles Jesus had 70 disciples he sent
out on the day of Pentecost it says
there's 120 in the upper room and three
thousand were baptized so if you read
the whole chapter of chapter seven you
read in verse 9 it says and after these
things I looked and behold a great
multitude that no one could number of
all Nations tribes peoples and tongues
standing Before the Throne of the Lamb
they are clothed in white robes so
there's a great multitude that cannot be
numbered and John says who are these a
raid in white robes
and the angel says these are they that
came out of Great Tribulation
so if you think of a Great Tribulation
at the end of time it says there's a
great multitude that comes out of that
don't think of the hundred and forty
four thousand as the only one saved
think of them something like they are
the leaders in Acts chapter 2 God had
the 12 apostles after they replaced
Judas they were down to 11 because Judas
hung himself they replaced Judas then
God pours out the Holy Spirit the
twelves start preaching plus 120 in the
upper room and a great multitude is
reached it's the same scenario in the
last days except it's not 12 it's 12
times 12 000 Spirit-filled leaders
that'll be around the world doing this
work they are not the only ones saved we
have a book pass to Doug it's called who
will sing the song understanding 144 000
and it's about this important group you
read about in Revelation chapter seven
just call and ask we'll be happy to send
you the book the number again is
800-835-6747 and you can ask for the
book who will sing the song
understanding the 144 000 you can also
get that by pressing pound 250 on your
phone and just say Bible answers live
and say I want the book who shall sing
the song and we'll be happy to send it
to anyone who calls and asks that's
right all right thank you Joshua we've
got Tammy listening in Washington Tammy
welcome to the program
oh hi pastors thank you for taking my
call
um I'm also a friend of Pastor Samuel
Thomas who knows Pastor Bachelor and he
has a lot of respect for you and he's
very busy person and I know you have to
show so I have a question it's in
regards to
Revelation where God says that he's
going to wipe all the tears from our
eyes and take our sorrows away
um my kids were dedicated in the church
and I have a granddaughter and I know I
saw something earlier on a program you
did about saying that you're not sure if
all children will be in heaven or not
before the age of accountability if one
or more or both parents are not saved
so my question is is how is God going to
wipe away those memories if we have
loved ones like that that are not going
to be in heaven
yeah well and I think everybody has
faced that and you know probably if
you've lived a little while you've gone
to a funeral before and you really had
serious doubts about whether the person
had accepted Christ and what are they
going to see in the resurrection are
they going to be ready and how do you
cope with that well you know one thing
you do is you put it in the hands of the
Lord the Bible has an interesting
statement it's a very short verse King
David had a son named amnon of course he
had three sons that kind of went
sideways we had amnon Absalom and
adonija I'll begin with an a
and amnon did some terrible things and
he died suddenly and David mourned for
him and then it says in second Samuel 13
and David long to be with his son
Absalom for he had been comforted
concerning amnon because he was dead
in other words David said you know I'm
going to cry I'm going to mourn but I'm
not going to cry forever because I've
got other children that need my
attention and I got the kingdom that
needs my attention and I'm going to just
put this in God's hands
and that's why it says God wipes the
tears from our eyes because
you know facing eternity without someone
you love is a horrendous thought
but it would take a God then to comfort
you at times like that and think about
this
who loves people the most any Earthly
parent or God
and how does God feel about the
Millions if not billions
that are going to be lost forever that
could have had eternal life
he understands how we feel and I think
the whole universe there'll be a little
mourning there'll be some sorrow but the
God then at the end of the 1000 years is
when he says he wipes away all the tears
from our eyes
all right appreciate it thank you Tammy
we go Paul listening in Tennessee Paul
welcome to the program
oh yeah thank you so much for taking my
call thank you
yeah my question uh is in regard to what
happens after death been watching you a
long time I've learned a lot
um and I just want to know if you know
uh when we die if we're dead asleep or
if you know if we're dead until the
resurrection or if we go straight to to
God in heaven and I've talked to you
I've heard you talk about uh Corinthians
5 8 to be absent from the bodies be
present with the Lord and I've heard you
speak on that one but I'd like for you
to touch on Philippians 1 23 and 24.
um the part that's confusing me is but
it's more necessary for you that I
remain in the body so is he saying he
does leave the body when he dies and is
he consciously with the Lord
well when you die your Consciousness
certainly leaves the body because your
body decomposes and you don't resume
your Consciousness again until God
raises you at the resurrection which for
a Believer is going to seem like just a
moment
um
there are 12 examples of resurrections
in the Bible approximately
and in all of those cases none of those
resurrected ever made a comment on being
aware of anything while dead
Solomon said the living know they'll die
the dead don't know anything Jesus said
our friend Lazarus is asleep and then
they thought oh that's good he's resting
Jesus said no he's dead but Jesus
referred to it as a sleep
so when that's why Paul says we don't
need to sorrow
concerning those who have fallen asleep
and that's first Thessalonians chapter
four we don't sorrow as others that have
no hope
so
consistently Through the Bible it refers
to the Dead
as they're asleep
for them their next conscious thought is
the presence of the Lord and the
resurrection so you know I understand
people say oh our loved ones with the
Lord but it gives the wrong impression
because they're not there yet Jesus
hasn't come yet the Judgment hasn't
taken place yet so a person's theology
just runs into a whole Gauntlet of
problems when they think that people die
and go right to Heaven before the
resurrection and the judgment
and um and indeed the idea that they
would die and go to the lake of fire
before the resurrection of the judgment
is also a big problem
so uh the dead are unconscious until
these resurrections mentioned in
Revelation the first and second
Resurrection
so when Paul talks about being absent
from the body he's not talking about a
soul ascending to Heaven separate from
the body and being aware of what's
Happening Here on the earth he's just
simply meaning that to be dead that is
to be absent from the body and then of
course the resurrection is the next
conscious thing you know you see so
there's no time time lapse for the
person who died the very next conscious
thought is the second coming of Christ
right and let me you know I never did
the justice of reading the verse he was
asking about so let's read that real
quick Philippians chapter 1 verse I'll
go to 22. but if I live on in the flesh
this will mean fruit from my labor yet
what I choose I cannot tell for I'm
hard-pressed between the two having a
desire to depart and be with Christ of
course if he dies the next thing he
knows he's the resurrection he's with
the Lord Which is far better
nevertheless to remain in the flesh or
the body is more needful for you he said
if I stay here in this life it's going
to be more beneficial to you but
when Paul died he was executed by Nero
he went to sleep he closed his eyes and
uh it's been 2000 years but for him it's
not going to seem like that
yeah hopefully that we have a study
guide that talks about are the Dead
really yeah we do the study guide's
called all the dead really dead and if
you'd like to receive that the number to
call these
800-835-6747 so I asked for the study
guide It's called all the dead really
dead we also have a website called
deathtruth.com you can just go to it
right now there's some sermons on there
some great resources and we'll be happy
to send that to you you can also dial
pound 250 on your phone and just say
Bible answers live and ask for that
resource are the Dead really dead we'll
be happy to send it to anyone who calls
all right friends we're going to take a
brief break but we're coming back with
more Bible questions go ahead text your
friends tell them to tune in call in
with your Bible questions we'll be back
in just a couple of moments
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
did you know amazing bag free bible
school that you can do from the comfort
of your own home it includes 27
beautifully Illustrated study lessons to
Aid in your study of God's word sign up
today for this free Bible study course
by calling
1-844-215-7000 that's 1-844-215-7000
[Music]
thank you
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air
please call us next Sunday between 7 pm
and 8pm Pacific time to receive any of
the Bible resources mentioned in this
evening's program call
800-835-6747 once again that's
800-835-6747 now let's rejoin our hosts
for more Bible answers live
welcome back listening friends to Bible
answers live and we're here to do our
best to answer any Bible questions you
have we don't have all the answers but
we've got our Bibles here and we will
search the word together call in with
your questions that's 800 God says
800-463-7297 and you could also be
watching and listening on the amazing
facts Facebook page Amazing Facts
YouTube page Doug Batchelor Facebook
page Roku aftv I forget where if the
Lord is Blessing the program's expanding
my name is Doug Batchelor my name is
Jean Ross and of course in addition to
as you mentioned pass the dag television
and the internet we've got the probably
the bulk of our listeners are on radio
whether it's satellite radio with a
listening land-based stations and we
just want to greet a few of our
listeners we have a radio station
wrhp listening in Alabama I want to
greet those who are listening in Alabama
and also kqj in Alaska so if you're
listening on either of those two radio
stations and you have a Bible question
give us a call the number is
800-463-7297 that'll bring you here into
the studio we're gonna go to the phone
lines our next call is Glenn listening
in Ohio Glenn welcome to the program
good evening thank you very much for
taking my call
and you know I got a kind of a toughy
here okay surprise ending if I may say
that right out of the Clear Blue Sky God
said in the beginning and when he said
that he started a dispensation of time
and I think we're living in that
dispensation of time right that would
have the Bible which is not only history
but also prophetic events
and it takes us God said that he would
never pull anything off on his creation
that he didn't tell him about ahead of
time so I think a lot of the Book of
Revelation for instance is settings
things that are that are scheduled that
could take place
but
the uh the question I have is this
when the in Matthew it says that things
will get so bad
that even the very elect would be in
trouble and time would be shortened
because of that and then when time's
going to be short there's also a place
that says and time shall be no more my
question is is when we come to that time
in in the Bible in history prophetic and
historical things
uh and it says time shall be no more
what can we expect after time should be
no more all right thank you well you're
talking really about two things there
Glenn uh when Jesus said uh for the
lexic those days will be shortened
meaning there would be a time of
persecution and deception near the end
and God is not going to prolong the
misery of the righteous the elect will
be spared because the time of the
persecution and deception will be
shortened but in Revelation when it says
in time shall be more no more there's a
couple things happening one is I
understand of course that would mean
prophetic time is no moral the prophetic
times in the Bible are fulfilled and the
other thing is we've entered eternity
the righteous all have eternal life and
so our view of time is going to be
different from that point on in that um
uh yeah do you really celebrate
birthdays every year when you live
billions of years
but that's beside the point I guess I
think specifically you're referring to
the phrase where uh in Revelation
chapter 10 the Angel that's seen in that
Vision lifts his hand towards heaven and
says time shall be no longer and it's
specific they're referring to prophetic
time because that ties in with the
prophecy of finding Daniel chapter 8
verse 14. but time goes on after that at
least not prophetic time not a date per
se but time does go on until you have
the close of probation right and then of
course seven last plays in the second
company of Christ
all right well thank you Glenn we've got
Ben listening in Tennessee Ben welcome
to the program
thank you very much I'm so excited about
talking to you both Pastor Bachelor and
Pastor Ross have a quick question
I believe strongly believe that Jesus
didn't die on a Friday why are we
celebrating a good Friday today as Jesus
crucifixion and death okay if uh if
Jesus didn't die on Friday why are we
celebrating the Good Friday well first
of all uh most Protestants don't make a
holiday out of a good Friday that's so
when you say we celebrating it
um most Protestants don't celebrate it
and you got like Ash Wednesday those are
usually Catholic Traditions but let me
come back to you why why are you saying
that Jesus did not die because I believe
the Bible says Christ was executed on
the preparation day which would be
Friday so I don't have a problem with
that what is your reason for not
believing that
well I believe that he was crucified on
Wednesday evening because of the fact
that he said that he was going to be
dead three days and three nights three
full days and three nights and then that
was in the Passover day okay they will
be the the Feast of the 11th bread which
is was to be the high Sabbath which it
was on Thursday okay yeah let's talk
about that for a second I suspected that
you were talking about there's one verse
in Matthew 12 where Jesus I think it
starts in verse 38 or 39 he said uh it's
an evil and adulterous generation that
seeks after a sign and no sign will be
given except the sign of the prophet
Jonah for as Jonah was three days and
three nights in the belly of the fish so
the son of man will be three days and
three nights in the heart of the earth
and some people believe that means that
Jesus would be dead three days I think I
heard you just say that and not only
that but
um I I believe that some people assume
that that means he must have been
crucified sooner when Jesus says three
days and three nights there in Matthew
12 he's talking about his sufferings
the suffering is both suffering and
death the penalty for sin is not just
death it's suffering and death Jesus
didn't just die for our sins he suffered
and died and Thursday night when Christ
was betrayed he said in the Garden of
Gethsemane now is the hour of Darkness
the disciples had fallen asleep while
they were praying that's when his
sufferings began when the mob came to
arrest him Judas betrayed him he was in
the heart of the Earth for three days
and three nights not talking about the
graves talking about in the clutches of
the devil nowhere in the Bible do we
call the grave the heart of the earth
anywhere else so people have assumed
that was talking about just the tomb
Christ was in the midst of the devil in
the hands of the devil for three days
and three nights
Thursday night Friday night Saturday
night and he rose Sunday morning
so hopefully that helps I have a book
called The Sign of Jonah that will give
you more information on that Ben we'll
send you a free copy or anyone who wants
to know about that that's right just
call
800-835-6747 you can ask for the book
it's called the sign of Jonah and talks
about that verse where Jesus City being
the heart of the Earth for three days
and three nights our next holiday we
have is Tony also listening in Tennessee
Tony welcome to the program
Tony might be muted Tony one more time
Tennessee are you there yes I'm here
okay
and your question
my question is in Luke 17 and 3.
F uh
talking about forgiveness
if my brother uh
trespass against me just do I have to
forgive him
well let me quote what Jesus said uh in
the Lord's prayer that says forgive us
our debts as we forgive our debtors
now when you say forgiveness
uh you know I think you should always
forgive uh people because if you have
bitterness in your heart and
unforgiveness that hurts you that
doesn't mean if someone is taken
advantage of you you need to allow them
to take advantage of you again it
doesn't mean if someone has stolen your
car that you need to just let them off
without them being prosecuted because
they'll just go steal someone else's car
forgiveness you know is talking about
you you need to just you know release
the anger and the bitterness and let it
go out of your heart and forgive them
um you can read that Parable in Matthew
18 where Jesus said
if we don't forgive others considering
how much God has forgiven us our
forgiveness is revoked
the Bible says if we want to be forgiven
we must forgive
so am I answering what you're asking
three says that if he trespass against
me I can rebuke him yes but if he don't
ask for forgiveness
uh then I don't have to forgive him
yeah and I think he's talking about like
I said when it comes to forgiveness
there are all kinds of different uh
scenarios and you know if if your
brother does something that is
inappropriate behavior there's nothing
wrong with having tough love and and
telling them that uh what he did was
wrong
but um and forgive him
um but I think even if they don't ask
for forgiveness you want to forgive
because like I said uh unforgiveness is
like an acid that destroys the container
that holds it it just it'll corrode you
to not forgive I know people that were
mistreated and abused by their parents
that are dead and gone they're still mad
I think well what are you going to do
wait for them to ask for Mercy they're
dead so you got to let it go
all right well thank you Tony uh next
one that we have is listening in
Virginia it's uh nazrana nazrana welcome
to the program thank you so much good
evening Pastor Rossi and pasta Bachelor
thank you evening my question is from
first Samuel 18 verse 10. I've been
studying it and I got stuck on the pot
that says that the evil spirited from
God Came Upon Soul so my question is how
can an evil spirit come from God I
believe God to be loving and he's not
evil so what does this mean
yeah it's interesting that it you it
tells us that the Holy Spirit came on
David
but an evil spirit comes on Saul
um the evil spirit when it says from the
Lord it just means permission is given
by the Lord because Saul had rejected
the spirit of God and when you reject
the spirit of God none of us is a vacuum
if you say I want the light out of my
room
by virtue of your rejecting the light
you're inviting the darkness
and it's like the story of Job
where the devil came to God and said the
only reason job suffers serves you is
because you've protected him withdraw
your protection and he'll curse you
so God gave the devil permission to test
job
God had to give permission for these
evil spirits to take over Saul because
solid ultimately rejected the Lord so I
don't know does I'm hoping that makes
sense
yes it does make sense because I just
just God is Not evil so how does this
first like make sense to me so thank you
for answering yeah and of course you've
got the passage here in James versus God
doesn't tempt anybody neither can he be
tempted with evil and then again it says
every good and perfect gift comes from
God God does not send bad he he sends
good but sometimes God withdraws his
protection and bad will come in and in a
sense someone might say well he's he's
responsible God does sometimes allow
things to happen because we've rejected
his protection
okay next call that we have is Anna
listening in Ari and Anna welcome to the
program hi
Hi how are you guys hello
much better than we deserve
that was awesome
so and your question my question is
revelation 4 verse 5.
um
and from the throne
proceeded Lightnings and thundering
voices seven lamps of fire were burning
Before the Throne which are the seven
spirits of God and the seven spirits of
God is what I am confused about
yeah I believe that these seven spirits
it's not that God has got seven ghosts
up in heaven floating around these seven
spirits are seven attributes of God the
spirit and the closest I think you find
of that is in Isaiah chapter 11 and you
read verses one and two and it says
there shall come forth a rod from the
stem of Jesse and a branch will grow out
of his roots this is a prophecy of Jesus
who is called the anointed Anointed with
what the Holy Spirit listen to what it
says in verse two
the spirit of the Lord will rest upon
him that's one the spirit of wisdom two
understanding three counsel for might
five Spirit of knowledge six fear of the
Lord Seven
and so it kind of gives us seven facets
or attributes
of God the spirit and sometimes the holy
spirit's the wisdom of the spirit is
highlighted and sometimes the fear of
the Lord is highlighted so forth so I
you have anything to add to that or no I
think you're right past it is
highlighting seven attributes of the
Holy Spirit and it is interesting the
seven burning lamps of fire if you look
at the sanctuary imagery it was the
seven Branch Candlestick which the Bible
makes pretty clear it was one
Candlestick that had seven branches
coming out of it wasn't seven separate
counts that's a good point so it's one
Spirit but there's seven attributes
supportive of you very good all right
thank you for your call Anna we've got
Tim listening in uh Tennessee Tim
welcome to the program
thank you thanks
I've got a simple question for you I'm
sure
um my question is in
second Thessalonians chapter 2.
and I'd like to focus on
verse three
um
this is talking about the second coming
it says let no one deceive you by any
means for that day will not come unless
the falling away comes first and the man
of sin is revealed the son of perdition
I've always kind of thought that was
talking about
an event that happened during the
Reformation
but as I think about it it could be
something around the end times maybe
during the mark of the beast when
there's no gray area you've got to
either follow God or follow
this man of Perdition
yeah well I was wondering if this is
already taking place or not I guess
I think it's taking place
it says that there'll be this falling
away that happens before Jesus comes the
falling away is not talking about
falling in the world because Adam fell
six thousand years ago that's already
happened it's talking about a falling
away in the church this is a great uh
falling away a great apostasy that took
place during the Dark Ages where a man
and most Protestants believe this was
the position of the Pope that a man sits
in the temple of God the church is
called the body of Christ Christ said
destroy this Temple made with hands I'll
make them without hands the Bible says
we are living stones in this Temple Paul
said don't you know the ye are the
temple of God is talking about the
church
and that this power would sit
uh saying he is in charge of the church
a man
and to be worshiped as God sitting in
the temple of God showing himself that
he is God and you know you can even see
pictures of the Pope and again I'm not
trying to be unkind I'm just telling you
what Protestants believed you can see
pictures of the pope then he's sitting
on his throne between two cherubim well
that's what you had in the temple in
heaven God was between the two chair of
them so it's like a man putting himself
in the place of God and uh certainly
that power had incredible sway through
the Dark Ages uh received a deadly wound
and came back into Power again and once
again as an independent country
so we have a whole study on who is the
Antichrist of Revelation we'll be happy
to send the number for that is
800-835-6747 you can ask for the study
guide It's called who is the Antichrist
we'll send it to anyone who calls an ass
you can just dial pound 250 on your
smartphone and say Bible answers live
and also ask for that study guide who is
the Antichrist
uh thanks Joe Cool Tim we've got Lee
listening in Texas Lee welcome to the
program
yes can you hear me yes we do
okay good evening Pastor Doug and
Pastor Ross my question is how do I know
I have the Holy Spirit other than the is
there more than just the fruits of the
Holy Spirit or there are other ways
certainly may Jesus said you'll know
them by their fruits so one reason is
you'll you'll know by the fruits of the
spirit now I don't know that that means
that every person is going to have all
of the fruits of the spirit all at the
same time
but you know a Christian should know
what it means to experience love and joy
and peace and patience and these are
things we're learning also keep in mind
and this is so important people can have
the Holy Spirit in different degrees
otherwise the disciples certainly have
the Holy Spirit when Jesus sent them out
teaching and preaching but when they
were baptized in the holy spirit that
was a special filling of the Holy Spirit
above and beyond what a person might
utilize every day in their walk with
Christ so you know don't doubt now you
know I'm trusting that you do have the
spirit of you've asked the Bible says if
God's willing to give or rather if a
human is willing to give their hungry
child food how much more will your
father in heaven give the Holy Spirit to
those that ask him if you've asked God
for the spirit and you've asked him to
forgive your sins and if you do feel
conviction of sin and a desire to do
God's will that's the holy spirit that
gives you that desire
you know we have a book it's called life
in the spirit and it talks about the
fruit of the spirit and this will be a
great resource for you Lee or anyone
wanting to learn more about what does it
mean to have the Holy Spirit the number
for that is
800-835-6747 you can ask for the book
it's called life in the spirit and we'll
be happy to send that to you or just
dial pound 250 on your smartphone and
you can ask for it that way next caller
that we have is Spencer listening in
Oklahoma Spencer welcome to the program
yes thank you uh and God bless you guys
for your work on this program
my question is I recently heard
something that I had never heard before
and it was a statement that said that
not all Christians would participate in
the Millennium but those who had been
rewarded because of
there were several Parables that Jesus
had given where some are given rewards
and some are not and
they when they they took it that as the
Millennium and that Reign where some
would be in charge of cities and some
would not
like
I I just never heard of anyone putting
it that way I had always just assumed
that all Christians would go into the
Millennium
um but it it was interesting to me and I
was just curious what your thoughts
about that were
yeah the way I understand it is you read
most of what you find about the
Millennium is in Revelation chapter 20
that all of the saved are there in the
during the Millennium they may be doing
some different things during that time
but I don't see another Resurrection
where the save come up separate from
those that will enjoy the Millennium and
you know when you read about it in
Revelation chapter 20 it talks about the
Redeemed living and reigning with Christ
and sometimes people think well if
they're going to be reigning or who are
they raining over are they reigning over
the wicked meaning the wicked are they
alive during the Thousand Years but the
emphasis there when it talks about
reigning the greatest act of reigning
was when a king September is thrown in
judgment so the redeemed are going to be
participating in the Judgment that
occurs during the 1000 years and it's a
judgment of the wicked because the
righteous already saved so that's what's
really happening with this reigning it's
not that they dictating to people what
to do because the wicked are dead
they're waiting for their Resurrection
at the end of a thousand years but they
are involved in reigning in the sense of
judging and looking at their works and
Jesus said every man is rewarded
according to his works and the redeemed
are going to have some part to play in
that judgment
amen so hopefully that helps a little
bit and we appreciate your call you know
we have a study guide It's called a
thousand years of peace and it talks
about this 1 000 year time period you
read about in Revelation chapter 20 and
of course we'll be happy to send it to
anyone who calls and asks it's
800-835-6747 or pound 250 on your phone
thank you Spencer next holiday we have
is uh Al eldiberto I believe it is from
Rhode Island
hey uh thank you uh so much for taking
my call uh Pastor Bachelor and Pastor
Ross and uh I pray that the Lord
continues to bless and strengthen you
both uh in this Mission you guys are
doing fantastic
um uh work and I follow you guys for a
very long time this is my first time you
know making a call oh praise the Lord
thank you
yeah so my question
um is found at uh on job one six
and I can read advers if that's okay go
ahead it says now now there was a day
when the sons of God came to present
themselves before the Lord and Satan
also came among them my question is this
if sin originated from Lucifer the devil
and he was the first sinner how come he
was able to see God and not burn on that
you know another verse God used to walk
with Adam before sin but not after sin
because of sin Moses has to see God in
his glory you know God said you can't
because you'll burn because he was a
sinner so the question is so my question
is how come the devil was able to see
God it was The Sinner
yeah good question
um and you know I'd have to tell you
that my answer would be some speculation
um
the devil lived in the presence of God
for who knows may have been hundreds of
thousands of years as he slowly he was a
good angel named Lucifer and he slowly
began to resent God's position and rebel
ultimately
and then finally it broke into an open
revolt and he was kicked out of heaven
the Devil is a spirit Paul says we don't
wrestle against flesh and blood but
against spirits and so uh you know being
a spiritual being
and may be different than what would
happen to a human
when we're brought into the presence of
a holy God with sin
but yeah the devil
not just here in the Book of Job but
even before the his fall was in the
presence of God with sin in his heart
so it is somewhat of a mystery
that's right okay well thank you next
photo that we have is Emmanuel listening
in um
Maryland Emmanuel welcome to the program
we have about a minute
hi thanks for calling
yeah I must have made like I really love
your program and it really helps me a
lot praise the Lord thank you well real
quick what's your question
um my question is about Free Will and
salvation
um and but when Adam is disobey he
blamed them so how does really uh how
does Free Will in that process relate to
our Salvation
yeah well actually the very fact that
God had a penalty for Disobedience he
told Adam and Eve if you eat from The
Forbidden tree you will die it's because
they did have a free choice and they
they made the wrong choice that there
were consequences if they had no choice
if they had been predetermined to do it
then why would God punish them for doing
what they were pre-programmed to do
so it's because they had accountability
that there was a consequence and a
punishment but we do have a book says
can a saved man be lost and we will send
you a free copy that's
800-835-6747 to ask for that and Pastor
Ross we just want to tell our friends
that are listening if they did not know
the end of the program we sign off in
two stages we say farewell goodnight to
our satellite audience but stay tuned
the rest of you were coming back for
some rapid fire Bible questions in just
a moment
[Music]
podcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts International a faith-based
Ministry located in Granite Bay
California
Hello friends welcome back we thank you
for your Bible questions and a number of
you have emailed Bible questions to us
and we're going to try and take the next
two minutes or so to answer as many
questions as we can if you'd like to
email us a Bible question the email
address is balquions at
amazingfacts.org all right Pastor Dave
first question that we have here from um
Leanne she's asking how do you know if
you have been baptized by the Holy
Spirit
yeah well the baptism of the Holy Spirit
as we mentioned a moment ago is
different from just the conviction of
the Holy Spirit and the leading of the
Holy Spirit and peace you may receive a
baptism means that you are you know the
word baptism means immersed every fiber
is saturated it's like the ground in
California right now it can't get any
wetter and so when you're so full of the
holy spirit this is what happened to
David when he was anointed he was filled
with the Holy Spirit Jesus was filled
with the Holy Spirit at Pentecost the
apostles were filled but you know what
that began to dry out because then
they're filled with the Holy Spirit
again in Acts chapter 4. so the Holy
Spirit can you know baptize you and fill
you for Ministry and you'll know that
when you just are just full of the
spirit and feel compelled to share the
word of God and do his will and Obey him
it's a signal okay another question that
we have Ashley's asking
um why didn't Jesus speak of paying
tithe during his three and a half years
Ministry well actually he did
yes some people
Jesus told the scribes and Pharisees he
said you paid tithe and this is what
Matthew 23 23 I think said you pay tithe
of your mint and your anus and your
cumin these are herbs and you've
neglected the weightier matters of the
job of the law Justice mercy and faith
says these you ought to have done and
not leave the other undone do not leave
the tithe pain undone
so and then not just Jesus but of course
Paul in Hebrews and others talk about
tithe nothing in the Bible says that it
was revoked so it's still in place
okay another question that we have
Joseph is asking God says that he will
establish a covenant with Israel but the
Bible also tells us that God is no
respecter of persons is this a
contradiction
well the lord loves everyone wants to
save everybody but God needed to pick a
nation to make them the the
demonstration of his grace so because he
picked Israel to make them that
demonstration and be the recipients of
his promises and the Guardians of the
oracles did not mean that he loved them
more than others it means he had to have
someone be the messenger in The Courier
and Friends he wants you to know that
truth and accept it thank you for tuning
in and we'd love to hear from you check
out more from amazing facts on
amazingfacts.org God bless the we study
next week
Bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions
[Music]